Tom liked Saturdays because there was no school.
However, he did not like this Saturday. Aunt Polly said he had to paint the fence.
He hated painting the fence. It was hard work. He wanted to play with his friends.
Jim came along, carrying a bucket. He had to get some water.
Tom would rather get water than paint the fence.
Jim agreed to paint while Tom got the water, but Aunt Polly saw and stopped them.
The next boy to come along was Ben.
He was eating an apple and Tom was hungry.
"Hello, Tom!"
Tom did not answer. He pretended to be busy painting.
"Hey, Tom! It's a nice day. I'm going to the river for a swim."
"It's too bad you have to work!"
"This is not work," said Tom. "It's fun. I like it!"
"Really?"
"Of course! You can go swimming every day, but you can't paint the fence every day."
Ben thought about it. He was interested.
"Let me try, Tom."
Tom thought about it.
"Aunt Polly won't let anyone else do it."
"Come on, Tom! Let me try. I'll be careful."
Tom shook his head.
"I'll give you my apple if you let me try."
At last, Tom agreed. He sat down and ate the apple while Ben painted the fence.
Other boys came along. They all wanted to do some painting.
The boys painted the fence three times and Tom was rich!